no man's sky it's a video game where you
can explore in wander you can shoot
animals and spaceships and all that sort
of stuff you can be a be a cataloger of
animals there's loads of different ways
to play this game so well have the three
of us here I wanted to talk about some
of the ways we've been playing it at the
moment ah Peter first of all you play
more than any of us combat wise how much
that combat have you done cuz I've
barely scratched it because I'm kind of
terrified at the beginning I attended to
avoid avoid sentinels because the
shooting kind of sucks in this game like
it yeah it's really not good but now i'm
at the point where i'd see a sentinel
it's just a pain in my ass as one of
your rid of it so i think i've killed
like 50 or just over 50 styles at this
point but that's only with a concerted
effort to do so over the past like four
hours today there is some sorry have you
done it has your gun gotten better or
something like have you sort of managed
to achieve you know my gun has improved
but I'm not noticing that big of a
difference in its performance apart from
being able to because you can use your
mining beam to kill enemies as well
right in fact my mining beam is just as
strong as the blast attachment and it
doesn't I don't have to reload it it's
right so they're cooldown timers that
change noticeably apart from that the
strength of it outside of mining I'm not
really seeing a big difference right um
the space combat stuff is okay it's very
basic like hey here's the reticle you're
shooting based on the ship's flight path
trajectory and shoot in that little
circle and you're going to take him down
eventually I've only died in combat once
which was against a swarm of signals
including the quadrupedal ones right
there's like the one time I came here to
watch and plated it how are they yeah it
was the only time I died yeah so far um
yeah I don't know combat is there but
it's certainly not like any draw for me
yeah me neither are the subs I'm kind of
fascinated to see what have the pc one
handles I feel like to feel the vision
doesn't feel particularly comfortable to
me at least on the planet I've if it
kind of works in space but maybe on the
planets it feels a little weird um but I
wondering am asking keyboards whether or
not that will make it more fun might
make more accurate I'm sure about much
everything off I don't think it's gonna
be fun cuz there's not going
variety of challenge and yeah right it's
I most of the time is those drones it's
shoot sentinels or it's like murder
animals yeah and like the animals
actually catch me off guard more in the
Sentinels like I find myself getting
berated by animals that I just can't
seem to kill where a sentinel was kind
of hover in place right animals are just
erratically running around like chomping
at my heels so yeah let's talk about
some of those animals than some of the
weird ones you've seen because
exploration and like had you know
scanning these animals to fill up your
logs first of all every time you scan
like every time you go to a planet or a
solar system or you scan an animal or a
plant you can then sell that information
you like upload it to the global sort of
database and then from that you guys
actually a decent amount of money at the
start it's not bad yeah consider you can
land on a planet in scan maybe a dozen
things in your immediate vicinity and
make it you know cool 15 grand yeah it's
pretty cool um how what has been like
some of the weird animals you've come
across so far they're all weird they're
all like a mix of amphibian and mammal
or inexplicable like biology like one
just had kind of like ed it looked like
a rocket pyramid like a rock pyramid for
a heavy very my head yeah whoa I uh was
he was this was a dragging a massive
life yes not a sword knife behind a lot
of fog someone wearing a plastic bag
from helmet um I can look I can
recognize and appreciate the variety
that is out there and that I can never
predict what animals are going to be but
they are the least interesting thing to
me about this oh yeah there it's it's so
clear how randomized they are and they
offer me nothing of import other than
lazy money-making opportunities I don't
have to work very hard for it the
concept of being you know enamored with
how strange these things are is lost to
me after the 200th weird looking at him
did you like spore no I loved spin and I
love the animals in this game yeah I
don't know why it's like I wish I could
like rotate the models and stuff and
like pick them apart I love naming them
stupid things like I've got like five
different animals like t-rex dog at this
stage because they've all got t-rex I
haven't gotten into naming yet all right
I don't feel like like I know someday
someone might SATs the reason or I'll
probably be dead
yeah not like naughty naughty boy I'll
speed up the world somehow yeah we'll
see it that's what the thing is with
these crazy animals it's almost like
it's desensitizing me right away what
I'm gonna see down the road like if i
was born in real life and the first two
people I saw were like Hulk Hogan and
Richard Simmons the remainder of my life
the people wouldn't really interest me
or creep me out that much so I would
just go through life and I don't know
but I think I see these animals in my
arc that's probably the weirdest what
I'm gonna see and then you see one which
is like comparatively weirder but still
how much you if you like crank it up to
10 right away where do you go from there
I wonder cuz I saw some like all the
screenshots are going up now right so
like it's a dozen the guy over the IGN
had like basically looked like sort of
like a kaka demon where I was like this
floating octopus like yeah walk it that
was pretty messed up I saw what looked
like a watermelon it's just bouncing
around yes I've seen those two you know
what's what's really interesting to me
is that now that I'm seeing everything
else that people are sharing and stuff
they've seen right I'm noticing a lot of
parallels okay right oh I've seen that
animal except it was yellow not green or
I've seen that line of dialogue from
that person in the outpost right like
somebody was posting about you meet this
traveler from the Viking race and he's
talking about having a photo of like a
potential mate oh right really sultry
yeah I saw that okay like they're
actually there's variety here but
there's also like a lot of similarities
happening as I go I guess they give it's
like implied variety because of the
scale of the world right yeah I got
anything would be the case but then yeah
maybe when when you actually play the
game I've interested to play the second
time and see how much of that yeah I
comes in as well and what else can you
in this game you can scan things you can
I guess mining like are you enjoying the
mining aspect of us it's it's the
fundamental part of the gay Andy you
need you a certain image but you can
obviously do way way way more if you
just want to be like a traitor it's like
gambling right and you spend enough time
on a planet hoping to find something of
value and then when you do you find like
a massive cache of it here's like oh I'm
the man like you're just dreaming of all
the money you're gonna make your then
dreaming what you're gonna buy with that
money and so at that point the materials
and the deposits become the thing you're
going to buy like you're just it's the
means to an end and it's great to find
it but when you're on a planet that is
like super desolate
and there aren't many resources I just I
can't wait to get the hell out of there
I'm there for like five minutes like
nope no huge waste of time I'm so done
get me off this planet I don't want to
play this game right now take me
somewhere interesting yeah I'm that's
what I'm scared to leave the planet I'm
on at the moment because there are just
massive like columns of gold everywhere
and I in a space because like I love
going to the space station and then
seeing what the traders around you are
trying to buy I'll pay double for right
and then the fascinating thing which I
learned from Rob's video as well they
put up yesterday the five things you can
learn from other trade routes things
that you wish you knew ya a trade route
see if you watch the I guess the the
line like where they're fly yeah you can
kind of see yeah he likewise multiple of
these like space line you know Lines and
scam tracks yes chemtrails converge on
to one planet you might find a lot of
stuff there and and it's very true like
there was one plan that I went to where
I noticed that it did have a lot of
those and that was one where I found the
gravity knows i think they're called
that were worth like 50 K a pop right
and I were just all over the place go
anytime I picked one up like half a
dozen send nose would come after so it
was like I'd like to take a deep breath
get out of my ship scan the area and
just sprint sprint sprint oh he's
keeping an eye on where my ship was
making sure i could get back yeah you're
tough to leave that sort of thing right
when you have those riches in front of
you and then you're making you're making
all this money in your like well when is
enough enough like how much cash do I
really want on hand or how much time do
I want to spend making them yeah if any
ask the question do you really need to
dedicate yourself to a profession now
you mind cell data fly a fight and traje
de to sort of min max or no those aren't
really it the game isn't like that at
all yeah there's no trade there's no
classes all these things you do are in
service of a bigger goal which is to
travel yeah the only thing I can think
of is at least at the start with your
because you've got your multi tool and
your starship and then your your suit I
guess is that like the multi-tool you
can sort of like put upgrades in it
which favor maybe com bash or favour
mining but like yeah you're doing both
all the time anyway right yeah subtle
difference Mike what about you one of
your first three or four hours in the no
man's sky been what have you been
focusing on I think once i found a space
station where i could sell things i was
mining just to see how much money i key
I don't forget what I'm sitting at now i
think i have at least 150 unit 150 k
units or something i was hoping that I
could be like a pirate pre-release which
I don't know if you can / say shoot down
ships in the air and collect materials
off of them but it's generally the same
thing as you're collecting it's usually
titanium cuz that was my dream like to
go pirate someone and destroy their ship
take their resources get ready to pulse
jump with the guitar solo from like free
bird playing the middle finger in the
air and get out of there you just want
to be cowboy bebop er yeah essentially
but yeah I heard your cowboy bebop
that's what I've been trying to explore
as much as possible but the the light
survival elements have kind of taken
over and right now i think i'm still
such a shallow part of the game that i
haven't really mastered inventory like
management figured out what what are you
what elements are used for what so far i
wanted i wanted I'm just upgrading my
ship in my exosuit as well as often as I
can I think that's my main goal in the
short terms I've gotten to a third solar
system i believe i did the second like
tier of the actual ad list question
upgrade your hyperdrive or whatever this
warp drive so yeah I kind of like
splitting it between economy the mining
and actual just upgrades to myself and
my ship which is rewarding let me tell
you right now stop upgrading your ship
thanks amigo by because you cannot add
slots to your ship the only way to get
more slots is to buy a new ship which
you can then fit more augmentation and
that's the same weight because you about
current like lasers on your ship though
for new ones you can swap it out yeah
but better i'm saving it for the next
ship how do me know if it's better off
that way but when you buy a new ship
they come with augmentations yeah
already okay so sometimes those are
already better than yours okay um and
then you're not scrapping things or
wasting resources to only sell it for
house unsane with the multi tool as well
eventually you're just gonna get like
you've got enough money to buy a better
one yeah well i have the i haven't used
them I felt cheap using them but I have
that pre-order ship and oh yeah I
haven't man everyone's got these nice
pewter ships I look like the ship that
you saw like on the cover just with the
different colors hand and I am like I
want that x-wing thing that had no
screenshots it's on the cover that's why
I'm thinking of that's the Joe is an
x-wing doesn't know think so that's what
randy has that's why I've seen a couple
with pre-orders that maybe it is maybe I
didn't look at it closely yeah
hey zones got Sean Murray's face all
over his lie it's not a B wing me and
Josh Shaw it's not Star Wars I know it's
not a star but I just need two things to
you sorry about how stupid bee wings are
the same watchin yeah honest account
makes a good point here which basically
kind of sums up her if I feel by this
game isn't that just elite dangerous I
mean I really liked playing Lee
dangerous but elite dangerous was like
too much for me like I'm not that person
like I you have to dedicate it's like if
I feel you dedicate yourself to that one
game to me this is exactly decide the
game all wanted this is a very except
accessible game yes it's like a denser
or like a more compact version of of
that right yeah it's not like you're
traveling it's not soaked it's a elite
dangerous is broad and has no rules this
one is quite guided at the stars and I
guess it continues to be guided
depending on what you want to do um yeah
and I'm we're liking it I wonder if
you're gonna be a peter brian i do I
don't know it's tough because the
question is do you go to the center of
the galaxy yes but there's another
question do you follow atlas this sort
of mysterious force that's pulling you
in a different direction then there are
other things there are other things i
thought atlas was pulling you toward the
center no this can't that these are the
sort of things that when I'm talking to
people it's like you have to reach it
you re explain it to everyone because
this game is so it's accessible but it's
not straightforward yeah the whole thing
with Atlas is counterintuitive to the
center of the galaxy like I've at this
point maybe four or five Atlas
interferences into the Atlas trail where
you kind of appear at these like temples
mmm your character begins to question ok
I'm not headed towards anything am I
just going in circles I don't know do I
want to keep searching and figure out
the answer mmm yes or no and so if you
choose yes it's like I'll keep going but
you're not getting any closer to the
center of the galaxy like with Alice I
in fact in my experience doing it I'm
literally going yes its effects like do
I want to do this right sure so if you
go to the center of the galaxy you're
actually there's not much of a story
there I did that when I was playing
before the patch and I actually got kind
of disillusioned in in terms of my
pursuit because it was so much about how
I made it not what not about what was
presented
right stage so I'm enjoying the Atlas
path more but it's there's no certain
end so in terms of women review is
coming I'd love to say by the end of
this week it might bleed into next week
alright but we have review a review and
progress up and you're going to be
continuing to sort of update that thread
yeah every day I'm gonna put up a
gallery with some of the coolest things
I saw and just moments that made me
think one thing or another and i'll be
sharing those every evening cool awesome
so check back on King spocom real soon
for all that hot stuff